good to see both of you
danny the last time i saw you was on set
of magic mike xxl in 2008 i remember
that i remember that i remember you too
how could i have been a while how are
you i was about to have to get naked yes
i do remember this very clearly
all those moments one of those moments i
gotta congratulate you both on this film
it is absolutely amazing directorial
debut thank you thank you made me cry
made me laugh and made me cry everyone
who loves dogs needs to watch this and
channing this is
your own experience with your dog lulu i
mean sorry for your loss but yeah what
did lulu mean to your life and to your
family and having that companionship
oh man dogs are in the in the bond and
like what you get from that relationship
is it's truly indescribable i mean i
don't really know if
if i sat here for two hours i'd really
be able to like you know encapsulate it
all really but um i lost her at a really
specific time where you know i really
didn't want to lose my best friend you
never want to lose your best friend but
you know it was it was just kind of the
time i had to surrender you know she was
going to go she was really sick and
and uh i had to just kind of let her go
and and i came back and told my buddy
about this road trip i went on with her
and
last days and it was it was beautiful
you know like we got at least i got to
say bye to her and it just didn't happen
so quick and yeah it was uh it was a
gorgeous thing and and we we talked for
a long time about making that movie kind
of making the the goodbye movie
um but it was just a little too sad
it is
i don't know i can't do that
yeah it's yeah we wanted to make the
beginning of a relationship as opposed
to the end yeah and being more
emblematic of like what my dog lulu and
i was like real relationship was it was
an adventure like every day like so
that's that's kind of the movie that we
want to make yeah
and there are funny moments too i mean
the whole scene with the women and
different personalities and
your character doesn't get hooked up not
any luck so reid were you behind that
was that in the script or is that real
experience channing did that come from
your own life experiences i generally
love hugging multiple people at once uh
i i love big group hugs we we usually
start our days with them here uh i'm
just like everybody bring it in put your
mask on let's have a covered safe uh
group hug yeah we look we live on the
west coast so you know we love we love
to get weird over here so yeah
of our shocker life
we're all about living our best soccer
lives
you don't have good pickup lines do you
chatting no no i'm terrible that's why i
had to learn how to dance i'm not a i'm
not
does anyone have good pickup lines you
know that's actually a good point i
don't know if there aren't one okay how
about this oh god you were a fruit you'd
be fine apple
i'm in
i'm in i'm in a fine apple
pineapple pineapple pineapple get it no
okay forget it i give up too much wow
that was that was a
i'm not using that one
you guys are amazing i wish i could talk
to you guys longer hopefully i'll see
you in person one day soon magic mike is
coming again so i'll see you guys then
congratulations to both of you
bye
thank you thank you